[Music]
there's a there's armored dirt covered
in dirt that checks out he's dumb as
hell I'll probably be contributing a lot
to your graveyard
I don't know how pressing buttons I
guess no it was great
kill - that killed is good
welcome back to dirty RT the show where
we make the biggest piece of character
and we stick to our guns and we roleplay
as said character in this case it's
dirty RT and the game is outer worlds
Jake so I think everyone hates this
right now oh because previously on dirty
RT RT kills read the the Edgewater town
me Z it he's the mayor right something
like that yeah he's the head of this
establishment and yeah people didn't
take kindly to that so we diverted all
the power to Edgewater right and then we
will so we screwed over the oh yeah
you're right alerted yep there it is
I mean Oh screw it let's kill this town
I like how previously Pavarti was like
what are you doing and now she's helping
she's like totally with it oh I'm
getting out of here we'll be back with
bigger guns not even the gore of it the
windup she had she did like a fake spin
that was amazing
I'll kill them all look at that the
snakes come back killing off my garden
gunning down Reed Thompson yeah kill you
next Locke made our way back to
Edgewater we must tend to what remains
of the town and carry on with our lives
as best we may your vexing to me you
know injuring us with one hand helping
us with the other here I'm giving you
something to leave us be
it's a ransom you understand not a
reward a ransom you could fast travel to
Edgewater maybe it's safe there I'm just
here I'm actually just personally
curious if a town is like chill now nope
[Applause]
we got we got a little cool off we got
to wait a little bit longer I guess did
I ask you is then gonna work if you're
talking all the time heading out
go over and say hi all right you go you
go first
Oh God I'll give you tips the rag
dolling is actually pretty funny oh hey
Parvati come over here quickly we'll
check this out hitch does it take to get
Parvati upset I'm the only decent
mechanic Edgewater's God but every time
I think of going back I get this sinking
feeling because you killed your friends
I want to ask you something and you can
say no no can I come with you
I guess we don't mind what with him
being dead no that's good
yeah I've been thinking about that I
never got along with mr. Thompson but I
don't think he deserved to die
no it's Jam how that happened I swear I
didn't mean to don't lecture me Pavarti
I do what I want yeah I don't know if
anybody's ever told you this mister but
you got a violent streak what to make of
you this water was on the verge of
collapse before you showed up you sent
them power and now the town might see
another season it into coming back to
town maybe one day Edgewater will have a
garden where that cannery one stood you
ain't exactly a stranger anymore you've
done some kindness hereabouts
I don't think Edgewater the same let's
get out of here here we go baby this is
very much a dirty arty ships yes yes the
unreliable the unreliable - shaking
spewing out fire nice
[Music]
by the way I gave captain Hassan a
disguise apparatus of my own design
cutting edge technology years ahead of
its time I call it the holographic
shroud I'm sure it will prove remarkably
useful to you you'll find it in the
captains quarters
you owe me work a wrong matter of shroud
mind slow-witted accomplice this is
simply a device that makes you look
different sound different briefly and
remember don't trust the board they'll
try to win you over with promises of
wealth and power but it's a lie the
board's only interested in filling their
own pockets if we don't put a stop to
them they're going to run this colony to
the ground hey captain I heard that
ground breakers got a real good engineer
a lady named June late Edison she can't
be that good his place is a dump
I had a fix a station this big I'd be
spending all my time trying to figure
out what needs doing now and what can
wait yeah my name is dirty Hardy for
something you've got a ship but you've
never visited groundbreaker you must
have just dusted off from one of those
dirt side outposts sure did
and now we're in space and I'm dirty
Arnie I'm sorry to tell you this but I'm
about to ruin your day according to your
ship's record you've been flagged by the
board your ship will be impounded until
such a time as they see fit to lift it
bullcrap so I'm stuck here not stuck per
se you could always throw yourself out
the airlock
you probably riled up the wrong petty
board bureaucrat and then you dumb bed
yeah let's drain him out no yeah I'll
ring this Bedford's guy's neck
you take the starch out of him well you
won't hear any complaints from me oh and
if you're headed that way would you mind
doing me a favor I'm not going to do job
[Laughter]
ah yes
wheeler messaged me you were coming you
must be the captain of the unreliable a
vessel that used to be helmed by one
Alex Hawthorne and you are not he has
something happened to my favorite
scruffy freelancer I'm gonna punch that
mustache off your face
Alex is important we're turning all the
frat let's pin Arang your scrawny neck
you spray right right you're going
important places I'm sure big exciting
important places there remove the flag
from your [ __ ] damn right
[Music]
that was the most badass in this game
give me back my ship you speak oh it
reminds me of the other guys of welfare
always like Gator needs his gun back you
punk-ass yes
he killed gizmo someone's got him do you
know Edna over an engineering Suite is a
P that one on occasion shall pass along
transmissions I might find interesting
she sent me a recording of a distress
signal she'd scraped from the ground
breakers calmer a curious thing is it
came from an outpost called Rose way and
auntie Cleo a bend in that place years
ago
Oh No host message aren't you precious
[Laughter]
great fancy running into you again
don't mind me it's just admiring your
ship from up close
got to hand it to you boss that's a
fine-looking ship only thing it's
missing is me stay away from my ship you
four layered clothing freak
get lost I get it you don't like seeing
a guy staked out next to your ship
it looks like I'm trying to ambush you
or sell you something just give me a
shot that's all I'm asking
I could be the best damn crew you ever
hired he could be good target practice
I've heard enough you're Irish yeah
let's do it wow that's free inline with
dirty already
[Music]
what happened I don't had enough of this
I'm just on tarmac guard no one said
nothing about fighting no raps didn't
hear you the one you do that for free
you're powerful free with that tongue of
yours been enough of your nonsense Oh
already attack you're gonna do something
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah you got me
just testing your mettle not much fight
left me anyways yes I thought scientists
Naima Anton crane
someone said he's panicking inside the
comm center
you if you've come to end my life let's
be on with it okay oh not actually one
of them are you
three or that if you want to go that one
[Music]
[Laughter]
auntie Cleo didn't like that the doom
that came to it I should probably reload
he's dead why you think well he's gonna
like point me in directions on how to
get do the quest it failed it Oh
straight up I missed that whoa that was
quick
dirty Artie did you do the mission yeah
that was literally to go I gave you he
said someone was trying to kill him so I
killed them hey okay here's our money
that little opportunity I told you about
on Rose way yep you don't care yeah
someone will get your snooping around
there before you do
[Music]
know
oh I guess I can't do anything about it
maybe I can sell things
sorry chief Dennis and I'll get the
radiators fixed soon
of course this heat sure makes a zero-g
brew extra refreshing it's a nail that's
good for what ails you
oh it's Martin hey Martin still we're in
the head how observant I'm authorized to
state that this uniform is more than
headgear it's a state of mind and our
customers know the difference oh and
it's not the best choice it's spacers
choice taste the freedom lot of slogans
to keep track of and sometimes I forget
I'm bound to satisfy headgear related
inquiries please send any complaints to
our consumer care headwear division STIs
you would never ask
if you it's like in here
I mean why anyone can be spacers choice
consumer relations choice specialist
just keep your nose clean and aiming for
the moon just speak up a good you doing
all right in there oh I'm having a
stellar day not just because I'm legally
obligated to say so
almost as stellar as a spacers choice is
affordable can you season hmm I could
see all on a top quality merchandise in
the spacers choice Catalan nice which is
available here at a local price 30 brush
your teeth is that we don't sell
toothpaste at this time but we're always
working on delivering exciting new
products to our customers spread wash
mouthwash and manta floss are among the
exciting line of dental Goods currently
in development
[Music]
you'll find none like them on all a
groundbreaker or anywhere in the house
so obsessed if you sleep with him
eclipse mich that's two handfuls of pet
pills washed down with a hearty swig to
our energy room a blast will send you
through the stratosphere and the crash
will knock you out gold guaranteed yeah
yeah yeah a compressional 10% to your
purchase today and the proceeds will be
donated to spacer cares
our premier corporate welfare program at
spacers choice we care about your health
and emotional well-being that's why we
put Martin through six years of vendor
school only to make them wear this do
you even if my contract didn't forbid it
I think I think it's part of me now are
you ready to make spacers choice lunar
green moon mouth lozenges a part of you
lunar green the future is spearmint are
you okay yeah dammit I'm smoking for
that one look this hat my job it may not
seem like much to a brave space captain
but they're all that I have if there are
self-made Purgatory's then we all have
to live in them mine can be no worse
than someone else's now if we're done
with the chitchat I hope you don't mind
if I make the most of this short life
and try to be the best moon person I can
be
first you learn mud it's fine
I should be stronger than this taking an
interest
speaking of interest can I interest you
in some quality budget goods at spacers
choice we cut corners so you don't have
to well that's gonna do it for this
episode of dirty arty - oh I think it's
pretty obvious that we're gonna do our
best to turn in Phineas wells maybe
we'll do it next episode maybe we'll do
it soon after that but do stay tuned and
thank you guys for watching
[Music]
you